[MUSIC]
I was diagnosed with dystonia when
I was 12.
[MUSIC]
Dystonia is a neurological disease
that basically means that some part
of my brain is just a little bit
unusual.
For me, it was in one leg,
then it was in my right hand.
And then it was in my left leg.
And then I had tremors.
And then my speech was very
slurred.
I struggled with it
through high school.
I somehow stopped writing with my
right hand and taught myself how to
write with my left hand.
So, overcoming obstacles is
something that I'm used to
finding solutions to.
After business school, it became
really, really tough to walk, and
I remember walking 56th Avenue
in New York City.
And it's really a long block and
those blocks would take 45 minutes.
It just became really hard and
I just started to look, what would
my life in a wheelchair look like?
I'm a nerd, and
this is a major theme of the story.
I built a spreadsheet and
the spreadsheet was, what
are the pros of brain surgery and
what are the cons of brain surgery?
But I just sort of did the
analysis, I realized I had nothing
to lose but to have brain surgery.
Eight weeks after,
I was walking the same block,
56th Avenue,
and I realized what was taking 45
minutes took 4 minutes and
I got to Sixth Avenue,
still makes me emotional.
I just feel like crying and
laughing, and
I never felt that feeling probably
since I was 15 years old.
I started running December 4th,
2006.
For anyone who runs out there as
you know, you always remember your
first race and you always
remember the escalation process.
I did probably a couple more 10Ks,
and then I was, if I can do a 10K,
why not do a half marathon?
The thing with me when I'm running
is I actually have to think about
every step.
So I have to consciously think,
lay my foot flat, lay my foot flat,
whereas most able bodied
people just pitter-patter.
[MUSIC]
But I always have my sights on
the greatest marathon in the world,
which I believe is
New York City Marathon.
I did it in 2018, and it's probably
really one of the best marathons
you could ever run.
That was just a dream come true.
I had written about in my GSB essay
that my dream in life was to one
day run a marathon.
It has truly been remarkable
what science has done to change
my life and
to give me the miracle of running
[MUSIC]
I always tell myself every morning
that I have a superhero cape.
And for me, woman's health, which
is super interesting because we've
been fighting for representation in
the healthcare field.
The beauty about Telehealth is you
can do it in the privacy of your
living room,
you can really tell your healthcare
needs n a non-judgmental way.
I've made a conscious decision to
use my platform to talk about,
how this affects marginalized
communities.
The people who are usually going to
get caught in the fray are people
of color, people of lower
economic societies, and people
in marginalized communities i.e.,
transgender people.
Simple Health is a reproductive
care company which offers
services to women and
people born with ovaries.
Right now we currently do
birth control.
So you come online,
you go on simplehealth.com,
you figure out online consultation,
a doctor reviews it, he gets back
to you with your medication.
And then we send to the pharmacy
and you should get your
prescription within three to five
days, all discreetly from your
living room with a judgment free
doctor's appointment.
So again, we're super
proud of that.
[MUSIC]
So really having a business around
longitudinal care around
reproductive health.
No one's done it yet, but
I tell people all the time,
this is what the GSB does for you,
makes you dream as big as you can.
My thesis at Simple Health is that
we have to keep on continuing to
fight for people's rights to
privacy of their healthcare needs,
reproductive care or not.
One of the things I'd always said
to myself is when I grow up and
be a great CEO, I'm really going to
try and create a company where
the employee workforce matches
the patient or the consumer base.
I am super proud to say that we
are 47% people of color.
We are 46% LGBTQIA+, we're 36%
disabled, we're 10% single parents,
and we're 6% veterans.
We don't do this by checking boxes,
we just actually do it
by attracting the right talent.
[MUSIC]
I had always wanted to go
to business school since I was
probably seven years old, and
I think my parents thought,
what is she talking about?
We were living in Trinidad,
how does she even know what
business school is?
[MUSIC]
In terms of what Stanford has done
for me, it has just surpassed any
expectation that I've ever thought
about, has changed my entire life.
The way I communicate has made me
the leader I am today.
The power of leadership,
the power of empathy, and
really the power of communication.
So professionally that's what I
took away.
Personally just an incredible
amount of friends and,
[MUSIC]
I had such a great bunch of
classmates that never made me feel
different.
[MUSIC]
Never made me feel,
Disabled.
But I think because of that is
really why I can be the great
leader I am today or the person I
am today because of my tribe.
I'm proud to be a tribe, and
I think that the GSB and
everything else is
going to make such a great tribe.
[MUSIC]